Michael why should young people start
saving now by the time were sixty rising
sea levels are gonna have wiped out our
cities there's gonna be no more water to
drink why why do we even need to save
even if the zombie apocalypse you know
comes it helps that resources your
future self is going to be kind of mad
and disappointed at you if you don't
save and you're gonna need it
but the reality is is that most young
people today only have about six to
seven thousand dollars in their bank
accounts and that's being generous it's
tough okay but I think on the other side
of things there are people that could
probably save more who maybe aren't so
let's just say we save a hundred dollars
per month and let's say I saved til I'm
65 and that's 40 years of savings right
let's say that money grows at seven
percent by the time I made 65 I will
have somewhere in the neighborhood of
two hundred and sixty thousand dollars
okay so here's some maths for you what
if I am a barista and a yoga teacher who
also like sells her hair sometimes for
money do I have savings in my future uh
talk to me a little bit about debt so on
average young people in this country
have thirty thousand dollars in student
debt what country should we expect to to
avoid paying them
so there's a lot of different types of
accounts where you can save money and
hopefully have that money grow you have
a bank account if you work somewhere you
maybe have a retirement plan at work it
could be a 401k 403 B 457 a different
compensation plan you don't get that
unless you're working right basically
are you saying that I shouldn't start a
Kickstarter campaign for my retirement I
what if I'm a dog walker who makes $15
an hour but I'm also a yoga teacher and
a barista who is IRA Roth
so IRA IRA stands for individual
retirement account and if you do not
have access to a 401k at work or some
other sort of retirement plan that's a
great place to start right I get it kind
of if you put money into something like
an IRA or 401k Uncle Sam will not tax
you for that money until much down
farther down the road when you actually
retire and take the money out to use a
Roth IRA is a different sort of IRA
account okay okay and basically it works
opposite tax wise from the regular IRA
uh-huh bear with me so you pay taxes now
to not pay them later you got it in a
nutshell how can I become too big to
fail I do not answer that what did I
work at Costco giving out free samples
of like kale chips but then I also walk
dogs and I'm a yoga teacher at the same
time is that gonna be hard for me to
save money
well I love yoga's Michael this is been
awesome I've learned so much thank you I
hope everyone else at home has also
learned on this episode of how to keep
your cash
bye-bye we can wave wave
you